reg good morning let me start with a
poll question what would be more of a
surprise slash upset Celtics beat the
Cavs or Rockets beat the Warriors oh
definitely
Celtics beating the Cavs look no one
expected especially when Gordon Hayward
went down in game 1 for the Celtics to
have won the top two records in the
Eastern Conference
when Kyrie it was found out was going to
have extended knee surgery and was going
to miss the playoffs entirely no one was
counting on Boston to get past Milwaukee
let alone Philadelphia and now facing
LeBron James and the Cleveland Cavaliers
so I certainly think what the subjects
have done throughout this season what
Brad Stevens has done with with these
guys have been truly remarkable
so then getting past LeBron James to me
would be a bigger upset
look the Rockets up warriors I mean they
got the potential MVP in James Harden we
saw what Chris Paul did in that game
fire 41-point closeout victory versus
Utah
they've got wealth weapons and they've
got the best record and they've got home
court advantage so it'd be less of a an
upset if they beat the Warriors even
though they are the defending champs
what Boston has done is just been
fantastic for the league should LA
LeBron be a little more upset after Game
one I know because I do agree with his
comment because I approached games
during the playoffs especially series
that when we started on the road them
being a fill out series you certainly
try to win Game one if you have the
opportunity if it's a close game you'll
obviously go after it but when you're
getting blown out I do feel a lot of
times and how as I approached Game one
it was a feel out series see how their
garden you see what they're going to do
see how deep they're going to go into
their bench and once I think after that
first quarter when it was like what 39
to you know 17 or whatever
I think he took the rest of that game to
try to figure out how is Marcus Morris
Hollis smart how is Tatum brown how are
they defending me and us look they
missed a lot of shots on particularly
threes which that's why they've been so
successful not only this year but
throughout the run during the playoffs
because they've been so efficient from
the three-point line
the Celtics took all that away so I
think this was more of a feeling out
process game for LeBron now look they
lose Game two and they play pretty much
the same way this series is a wrap but I
don't think it's time to panic remember
they lost game one versus Indiana and
found the way to win it in seven so I
think the real parameter will be Game
two how they approach it look Kevin Love
must be better but I mean it's so simple
in a game of basketball it's make or
miss League they've got to be better
effectively shooting the basketball from
three and really that was regular-season
defense that they played against the
Boston Celtics in Game one they've got
to be much crisper and sharper at the
defensive end as well here's LeBron
after the game reciting a two minutes
stretch where he thinks this decided the
game and the dance and I differ on how
impressive this is here's LeBron what I
think they scored seven quick ones
anything what happened there what
happened we ran him the first possession
we ran him down all the way to 200 shot
clock Marcus Morris missed a jump shot
followed it up he got it big out of dunk
we came back down we ran a set for
jordan Crawford I mean Jordan Clarkson
and he came off and missed it they
rebounded it and we came back on the
defensive end and we got to stop they
took it out on the sideline
Jason Tatum took the ball out threw it
to Marcus smart in the short corner he
made it three we come back down missed
another shot and then 10 who came down
and went 94 feet did it yo step I made a
right-hand layup timeout
there you go a round of applause reg
look as oppressive as that is every NBA
player particularly the great LeBron you
could ask Chris Paul James Harden Steph
Curry Kevin Durant in our series they
can recite games from their AAU days
look this was one thing that as a player
you live and die and breathe the game
and as much game film as you watch you
just played the game and it isn't a
constant loop in your head after the
game as you're walking through the bus
as you're on the bus back to the hotel
while you're on the plane you are
constantly replaying the games where you
can be better where they made runs look
I still shake my head when I'm on a long
bike ride on certain ways against the
Knicks and against Jordan it I think
it's Kobe and Shaq and the Lakers you
know you just keep replaying and loops
certain sections of games you know to
this day
so as the precedent as it is for LeBron
James there's a lot of players with that
high IQ that could verbatim tell you
exactly what happened throughout the
course of a game throughout their
careers back to their AAU days but I do
I gotta give them applause because to
him that was an important stretch of the
game in that third quarter where they
finally started to make a run where
things went south for them Reggie's on
the call Game one Western Conference
Finals tonight between the Warriors in
the Rockets give me an over/under on the
number of three-pointers attempted in
Game one in this year's Wow
well the Rockets are gonna shoot 40-plus
yeah so that's a given
they've been doing that throughout the
playoffs though they were down I would
say five to seven threes in that Utah
series because Utah's a really good
defensive team I say the Rockets shoot
[Music]
35 so I'm gonna say this but there's
gonna be about 30 to 35 there's gonna be
70 plus three tonight
and
I am actually gonna play five minutes
because of that I will get to a half
minutes with the rocket in two and a
half minutes this is my kind of game
tonight oh my gosh yeah it's gonna be
great I mean this is what this is like
you know Foreman and Holly
Liston ollie this is one of those
heavyweights where you're gonna remember
where you were throughout this series
because all season long people who were
like Houston Rockets they're the one
team that's built to take on the Golden
State Warriors we want the Warriors we
want the tabs well guess what you gotta
hit the champ and get the opportunity
and you have the champ the chance in
your building to start Game one two
let's go at it the most valuable player
in this series is going to be who not
the best most unable for the Rockets it
will be Clint capela defensively because
they are going to switch everything
especially the high screen and roll with
Steph Curry and in the series between
Minnesota and Utah the ability for
capela
to keep the guards in front and contest
every shot made it very difficult for
those opposing teams so his effort that
both ends of the floor has a spectacular
I think he's in the second best player
you could almost make a case for him
being the best player because a space
James Harden has been great in Game one
in both series but he's been up and down
and Chris Paul has had flashes but the
guy that's been the most steady has been
capela so capela for the Rockets and I
will say klay Thompson because so much
focus is going to be on Steph
and KD clay is just gonna be able to
roam free offensively and when he's get
it when he's clicking offensively it
takes him to a different level but more
importantly I think he's going to start
off being a prime or primary defender on
James Harden so there's going to be like
five guys guarding him but defensively
his work on James Harden will be huge
so
I think Thompson were the Warriors and
capella for the rocket Kobe Bryant
echoed what I've been saying all season
long that maybe Ben Simmons is
right-handed not left-handed and you got
to break that jumper down here reg what
do you do with Ben Simmons you already
have marquel folds who's got issues with
his jumper Ben Simmons can you improve
that jump shot oh absolutely you can
improve it a lot but didn't send the
test don't want to improve if I'm the
Simmons
I am absolutely living in the gym this
offseason and I don't care if he's left
right-handed if it's a push shot if it's
a mama shot and he shoots it with both
hands he has to put the time and work in
it and to me all the great players
always come back adding something that's
the last thing he really needs to his
game and he this will be his third year
even though people are calling him a
rookie I think if he adds a jump shot it
doesn't have to be all the way to the
three-point line but if he can add a 15
and 18 and maybe a long 22-footer
you know feet on the three-point line
this young man will be unstoppable
because but rich he doesn't have a
10-footer right now I know that's that's
a lot of things he has to add that to
his game if he looks that was the knock
on LeBron James right he couldn't shoot
and you're not a great shooter now but
he keeps your honor shooter right now
Ben Simmons does not keep anyone on it
he just tries to bull you and he can get
away with that but as you saw as for the
longer he goes throughout the playoffs
and the better teams and the better
coaches they're gonna take all those
things away from them it'll be good for
my night to night basis during the
regular season but all your flaws get
exposed the longer you hang around late
April all of May and if you want to get
into June those awards start coming to
the surface I just think it's it's
difficult there's no form there
whatsoever even on his free throws you
can see that doesn't have to be perfect
he just has to keep the defense honest I
would stay in the lab he needs two to
three hours he doesn't need a guru
shooting coach he needs his boys all
right I'm sure on the payroll but Reggie
gave you four months and that's what
he's gonna have here four months to get
that jumper ready for the regular season
what would you do would Ben Simmons it's
repetition it's repetition repetition
repetition and I would start like you
said in I would start at ten to 12 feet
and I would go around the world certain
spots I'll need to be Steph Curry and
going through my legs and pull up I need
spot shooting so we're gonna start ten
feet on the baseline and we're gonna
shoot 100 and you've got to make 75% of
them then we're gonna go to the next
spot the 45 degree angle shoot a hundred
of them and you got to make 75% of them
all right and we're gonna stay here
until you get it done you don't like it
then you're not as great as we all
thought you want to want it to be but if
you but reg if you have bad he has bad
form he has to improve his form before
he does any of that stuff
because what you're doing come with
repetition Theodore that's what I'm
saying right now I think he just shoots
to be shooting and I don't care about
the form I had terrible looking form but
to me it was repetition I got
comfortable with the way I shot but you
had greatly follow-through though your
your follow-through it's like your shot
was like Jim Furyk sculp shot it may not
look normal or pretty but at the end
you're at the same spot that everybody
else is and that's all that matters Ben
doesn't get there at the end of the day
the more repetition I would do with him
if I was working with him that will come
in time because there are certain shots
when he does shoot them he does hold up
the gooseneck it might not look pretty
but he is trying yeah would you rather
have Lonzo ball shot or the potential
that Ben Simmons may have with his shot
man that is a great call
I would I would go with Ben Simmons
right now that's the wrong answer at
least Lanza who's a better shooter
okay who's a better shooter at the end
of their career
as we look back Lonzo bar Ben Simmons oh
that's book this well hold on first of
all ball is gonna be he's gonna take way
more threes at the end of the by the end
of their career than Simmons so it's
hard to beat that
because Simmons will take less threes
but a higher percentage will be well
that'd be big lot after year five let's
do that let's revisit this after year
five who has the better percentage yeah
but Ben is all of his shots are four
feet in he's old for 11 from three-point
range I don't know what he shot from
five feet out but he doesn't shoot well
like his range is four feet it Lonzo hit
93's this year now granted 30% but he
hit 93 x' this year you like 93 by year
5 by year 5 is that wait is that total
of 5 years could you beat if I
blindfolded you could you beat Ben
Simmons in a three-point shooting
contest I want to take those eyes and
you know what I probably begrudgingly go
with you do you thank you yes I probably
would I would just please to prove these
or am I wrong because when you get a
three-point shot it's gonna be lights
out it's on it you got to keep them
honest
that's all that's remaining in your game
would you rather have Lonzo ball Donovan
Mitchell or Ben Simmons future Ben
Simmons then Mitchell sim ball okay now
throw Tatum in there and all that it's a
different story would you say example
for all of them
no I would take still Simmons then who
hate him is good man he is but he's
that's a true that's the future if
that's the NBA future right there yeah
that's not he is going to be complete
yeah yeah he sees I be a man
Tatum's pretty good man are you taking
Tatum over Simmons in five years who
would you want
I'm gonna go Tatum I can't I can't argue
with you I can't well by the way are you
in the uncle drew movie
I am lights out baby
lights out that's my character so are
you playing but here's the thing I play
I'm not legally blind but I've lost my
vision I was the best sniper on huncle's
Drew's team back in the day on our
record team but father time is caught up
to me and I think I'm still the baddest
shooter but I brick everything so
getting into character was very
difficult for me they had this shot on
purpose and you know how hard that is
for me yes
so the Daniel day-lewis had to come out
of any and the method acting was at its
finest for me so that's great June 29th
uncle drew the best cast every day and
here by the way the basketball scenes
Chris Webber and I thank you very much
because when you watch basketball movies
you're like that would not happen come
on that would not happen well in all the
basketball teams
it did happen because we made sure of
that we were like no I mean they had a
guy on their door that were like no no
no we're good
if you all wanted to do this movie we're
going to make the basketball scenes look
authentic
so it's uh it's Kyrie is the star can I
read the star we got Shaq as big fella
we got C Webb as preacher
we got Lisa Leslie who is married to
preacher as Betty Lou we got Nate
Robertson who who was mute and doesn't
talk in his boots and my name is life
baby lights out look at you gray hair
and a beard in this movie oh yeah I look
Carol angle huh that's what my future
will look like but every day shooting
this in Atlanta for a month was it was
it was fun
so we transformed what the Rutger would
look like in Atlanta and you won't be
able to tell the difference in Kyrie was
putting on a suit it was probably his
best work of the season maybe that's why
he got hurt so much work on the hardtop
to make all these teams like they were
unbelievable but June 29th it drops
appreciate you Lionsgate it's going to
be fun all this and the premiere is in
New York so all you guys better come
[Music]
walking the red carpet you all you guys
are my date okay yeah but you know
whatever with me on the red carpet reg
you're gonna look like Coolidge and
we're the rest of the guys on the team
and the white shadow so I don't care you
guys are my team and y'all are walking
the carpet with me I'm dribbling the red
carpet how you get down y'all are with
me have fun tonight we'll be we'll be
watching Thank You reg you're the best
Theodore and my dad for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]